that there were many discussions, we
need her main Greek, but we
decided that we will not give a chance to steal
our children such a beautiful holiday. Like
St. Nicholas Day, we will not give a chance to lose the
New Year, Christmas, and we also nicknamed her
symbolically our tree of indomitability,
because we want to show that we  Ukrainians
cannot be broken and despite the great
challenges that exist today, even just
this morning there was a drone attack and a
kamikaze from Russia who want to
freeze Ukrainians, leave them without heat,
water, electricity, but
nevertheless, nevertheless, we are fighting and we ca
n’t be broken just like that,
kak kak  it is said to enemies for evil Well, we
do not wash with a smile, children need
some positive impressions that it is the New Year,
that she will not remember what war is,
in principle, this is a small piece of
joy for our people, even in such
dark times
, the generator works, which shows us all that
the war is still going on, there are power outages,
but the Russians will not be able to take away the holiday from us